hi I'm Monica the beauty expert I am
Ashley the coordination maven and today
we're gonna help one woman avoid a
quarter life crisis Naomi tell us about
your quarter life crisis I am going to
be a bridesmaid and my best friend's
wedding I have to find my bridesmaids
dress
and then I have to get ready to go to
New York and then I'm just a little
nervous cuz going to New York and being
in like a very fancy wedding with people
I've never met before and they're like
beautiful gorgeous women so I just feel
very out of my element just start off
like before we even get into all this
stuff you have to do those beautiful
gorgeous women you are one of them Moe
so we'll get to give you tips and tools
to help you be in touch with that truth
and not forget it when you're there
thanks guys - all open okay so here is
very carefully the one thing I'm really
worried about is I'm going straight from
the plane my red eye straight to the
all-day bachelorette party oh yes to
start for the skincare stuff I think to
make your routine fast and easier I'm
gonna recommend a Olay Total Effects
seven in one moisturizer is gonna give
you all the benefits of like all the
stuff you have it'll be one bottle so
it's travel friendly like it's gonna
give you the same brightening effect
combined with all the other stuff I have
to have two major outfits the first one
being the bachelorette party which I
hope you guys can help me maybe find
something in my closet that I can wear
and then the second one being my
bridesmaids dress I'm thinking like
maybe this dress you can like wear it in
the day and then
refile it tonight maybe like a this for
the night I mean you can keep the same
dress on all day but kind of revamp yeah
I like it really man I am so when I wake
up I turn off my alarm and then that
just leads me to be checking like all my
social medias and watching all these
videos and then I start comparing myself
to other people and what they're doing
what I'm not doing but it just doesn't
really set me up or to start my day
positively one thing I want to see
happen as we get you an alarm clock that
you can use instead and I want to help
you create a morning routine that is
going to rock your world so it's a
couple of days in and I've been
implementing some of the things that
Ashlee told me to do especially with
social media she gave me this which was
so sweet this is where my phone goes at
night so I don't look at it
especially when I wake up and then I
feel like my confidence is growing which
makes me really excited for the wedding
because I feel like I'm gonna be the
best version of myself when I get there
so I just cleanse my face so now it's
time to try the Olay 701 that Monica
recommended if he or she is already it
feels so good going on and then the
bonus is its travel size so you just
bring it on the plane with me I was
doing really well with like the not
looking at my social media in the
morning and then it was like the weekend
and I was like it's Saturday
I don't have anything to do today I'll
look at my phone in the morning and
we'll be fine like you know when you do
it it's not gonna make you feel good
it's not gonna make you feel like the
person you want to be so right now I
just feel like disappointed so tell us
how it's been going these last couple of
weeks I think I've had some really like
good things happened like with taking
care of my skin and using that
moisturizer you suggested and then the
other thing that I checked off my list
was I officially nailed down a
bachelorette party outfit yeah but I am
NOT doing very well with the other two
things that you guys gave me I'm
struggling with social media again and
then because I've been looking I just
can't get myself to like look up
auctions for my bridesmaids dress
finding this dress might be more fun
than you think I just feel like
sometimes I have like a block in my head
from like going shopping with my mom and
like never being able to like find
something that fits you know so I think
that's a real struggle that I'm dealing
with here give me you're gonna find that
dress and you're gonna feel so good you
know what you like and you're gonna find
damages okay thank you guys
okay so I have gotten my dresses in the
mail and I'm trying them on and this is
the first one and I don't hang it I
don't think this is the one I am like
having so much fun trying all these
dresses on alright you're not waiting
let's go anymore Pammy you clearly
killed this look this is a really good
fit so since you surprised us by finally
showing us this dress we have a surprise
for you
Melissa I think you look absolutely
stunning in this dress
what I love about it is I feel like it
combines me and you into a dress because
it's got the poof it's so you and then
the lace is so me and it just it's us
together in a dress I love it I'm so
glad I'm your friend and then I get to
be with you you're getting married
please I just wanted to say thank you so
much for everything you've done for me
now I feel like a more confident
beautiful radiant woman because of you
too so thank you
[Music]